you get in the metal tube zoom up 115
floors at a ridiculous speed to the top
of the ping and skyscraper
[Music]
then you find a window and marvel at the
sublime bigness of Shenzhen
[Music]
forty years ago all this was farmland
and dirt roads a minor hub for rural
Goods trading just across the border
from Hong Kong now it's the hot steamy
frenetic home to 13 million people that
just about everyone on earth calls the
Silicon Valley of China everything here
moves at what's known as Shenzhen speed
it's a phrase that describes an
unyielding pace of change and I came
here to feel it firsthand to do that
it's an Instagram pose with the
cityscape a quick scan for government
spy drones and then a car ride to see
where just about everything we use gets
made
[Music]
you hear about factories in China all
the time today I'm lucky enough to
actually go visit one that's located
about an hour outside of the center of
the city they're gonna let us see what
life is like inside one of these
factories there are grim factories there
are decent factories and then there's
this place run by grants and electronic
it's safe to say this is not what I
expected
the plush surroundings are intended to
make customers from all parts of the
world feel comfortable but inside it's
more like you'd expect dozens of workers
moving at Schengen speed making fancy
headphones for an Australian company
called Nura how did you guys end up in
Shenzhen I guess that's the thing to do
these days yeah
changes knowing there's a place that
people come to to make things yep
you don't come here to mess around you
come here to get things done they have
the supply chain here a supplier that
can make any component the headphones
you need and of course there's the labor
costs which is not cheap as you used to
be but still reasonable the production
line has been running at basically
maximum capacity since we started and
yeah we can do 500 a day Norman what are
the little noises we hear in the
background you're hearing them make sure
they assemble the speaker correctly so
that's a good test boys yeah that's
right okay but what is life like for the
people who make these wonderful toys to
get a taste of the factory experience I
joined the mad dash for lunch
hmm cafeteria food
how's that food it's good how long have
you worked here okay it's tough to say
anything terribly new about the life of
the Chinese factory worker most of these
people have come from China's
hinterlands often leaving their families
behind in their rural hometowns they'll
spend about two years on average in
Shenzhen busting their butts working
overtime to save up as much money as
they can
is it a step up from hardscrabble
subsistence farming probably are there
still safety nets yep but I can tell you
one major lifestyle advantage the
Chinese have over us qui lows when we
first started working here after lunch
we couldn't really get anyone's
attention eventually we can't learn
everyone's just sleeping at that time of
day that said we embraced it very
quickly
what is your preferred sleeping
apparatus I'm pretty Spartan so either
on the desk or under the desk with a bit
of bubble wrap for a pillow is good
[Music]
Luke is just one of many entrepreneurs
who come to get their gear made in
Shenzhen
there's a flourishing scene here for
hardware startups that want to move fast
and make things many of them can be
found here at a startup incubator called
hax the idea here is simple help
startups build a prototype then connect
them with factories that can start
cranking out their products by the
thousands take Jamie here an affable
chap who's part of a British startup
called Carter we make a key coach so
effectively it's like insert you put
into a ski booth and it teaches you how
to speed better so you get like
real-time feedback through headphones
like that was a bad turn
that was a bad turn that was a better
time you have one here yeah yeah so yeah
these are motion sensors that's spot-on
motion sensing crazy like many startups
here carved began life is a humble
Kickstarter campaign now just a couple
of years later they're pumping out 5,000
units of their product every month do
you think you could have brought
something like this to life for the UK
if you'd have been accepted by an
incubator there now that you've been
here you see it anew yeah world I guess
I think it kind of depends a little bit
on how much of a shoestring you're on
Darren shinjae and it's so much cheaper
in many different categories cheaper
like in the product development phase to
get different materials 3d printed or
machined you get it here for kind of
half the cost and twice as fast yeah and
sometimes seven times as fast
to get a feel for that high-speed energy
I hop across the street with Jamie to
the famed washing Bay markets yeah so
this is the biggest electronics market
in the world probably they're an
important resource for the young
entrepreneurs here in a fantastic place
to get your senses overloaded walk
through the market it's like bang yeah
they know like okay this is where
factories have come to display their
wares to potential buyers who is me and
I know all the other people here kind of
a storefront for factories okay and if I
make smartphones or TVs or anything like
that I kind of come here to see you want
to find a manufacturer you come to watch
on Bay it's also a great place to find
that missing part for your prototype
which is why you run into other crews
from hacks roaming the aisles find some
screws drinks
have you tried there's a spring woman
out the front as well of you on one just
on the left as you go the fact that I
can get a component in like an hour is
like absolutely phenomenal
that's like baddest engine speed yeah
that's why we're here
it's all happening here in Shenzhen like
some kind of crazy 21st century gold
rush but to really give Silicon Valley a
run for its money it's gonna have to
become more than just a factory to the
world it's gonna take invention an
original thinking and where better to
find those things then at the world's
most intense robotics competition we'll
get into it next time on hello world
thanks for watching and if you want to
see more hello world click on the link
to subscribe